[موسيقى]
لطالما وصفه باريس بانها مدينه الانوار
لجمال اضوائها لكن هذه المدينه الساحره
التي ياتي اليها السياح من كل حدب وصوب
تخفي وجها اخر مظلما لا يعرف سوى من عاش
فيها وتجول في شوارعها
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاحياء المهمشه يعيش الكثير من
المهاجرين غير الشرعيه الذين لا يملكون
اوراق ثبوتيه تخولهم للعمل بشكل نظامي في
فرنسا لماذا يلجئون للعمل بالاسود وهنا
يصبح هؤلاء اسرى في عالم شبه منزل لا
تحيطه حمايه ولا يضبطه قانون
[موسيقى]
فوزي مهاجر غير شرعي من الجزائر قدم الى
فرنسا هو وعائلته بحث عن ظروف افضل لكنه
فوجئ هنا بما كان بعيدا عن توقعاته فبعد
ان بدا رحله البحث عن وظيفه لم يكن امامه
سوى طريق العمل بالاسود اشتغل لمده عامين
كامل توصيل في احدى شركات توزيع المواد
الغذائيه عانى كثيرا من سوء المعامله
والاستغلال ومقابل اجرا زهيدا كان يعمل
حوالات 90 ساعه في الاسبوع متجاوزا بذلك
لحد القانوني وهو خمس وثلاثون ساعه
انا كنت اشتغل في شركه احنا خمسه اثنين
بدون اوراق
كل الشغل علي انا روح حمل اولا ثانيه
صباحا ثانيه صباح لكم لازم تكوني في
المستودع دنيا صباحا
يعني 15 يوم وحدي وفي شغالين اخرين ثلاثه
يستغلوا هذا المنطقه هذا تاع الانسان
[موسيقى]
يكاد يرتبط مفهوم العمل بالاسود بمنطق
الاستغلال من الصعب جدا ايجاد شخصا لديه
عمل غير مصرح به ولا يشكو من معاناه سواء
لناحيه زياده عدد الساعات او نقص في الاجر
او المعامله بعنصريه
وهي نسبه عاليه جدا
عندما نقارنها مع المناطق الفرنسيه الاخرى
التي لديها نحو اربعه في المئه فقط من
العمال المهاجرين وغالبا ما يشغلون كما هو
الحاله هنا مهنا متواضعه مقارنه ببقيه
المهن الاخرى في نسبه عاليه منهم يعملون
في المساعده المنزليه والطبخ واعمال
البناء والحراسه وفي هذه الوظائف في غالبا
ما تكون ساعات العمل متقطعه ويعمل فيها
المهاجرون باعداد اكبر من غير عمل المحدد